hi GQ I'm Hoya and these are the things
that I can't live without
[Music]
any hotel I go first meal at the hotel
it has to become with french fries
they're rich
in Paris has so good french fries the
Crosby hotel has good french fries I
can't choose in L.A I mean there are so
many good french fries
oh
ketchup I like to go with um basic
things
does that make sense
iced Americano I drink
at least
two glass of ice Americano per day
which I think I sleep a lot I think I'm
mostly a sleepy person so I need ice
Americano to just like
move
just you know like make my body move
when I'm filming a skit game I felt so
nervous so I need to take a break for
ice Americano because of it makes me
more kind of feel the heart pumping but
that was the only break that I ever had
in my life I took
the cuff iced Africa
[Music]
I think being an ambassador for Adidas
is I kind of want to dream come true
because of I've been wearing Adidas like
all my life I think since I was like
little chart they're so cool and then so
comfortable I can't wear you know heels
and uncomfortable shoes in my normal day
it's I think from my modeling career
where I have to kind of wear
uncomfortable shoes like what I'm
working so like no more day I'm like I
cannot you know just wear those heels
Adidas Samba shoes is like saving my
feet foot fit food fit
foreign
[Music]
I got it because of when I travel I you
know like from Korea to
us Korea to Europe it takes like over 10
hours mostly so I needed something that
felt comfortable even though I wear it
for 10 hours over 10 hours without
having this hat headphone I can't sleep
in the plane so that's why I cannot
leave it up this
had fun
I always listen music when I'm traveling
it's kind of random music from Korean
pop to like Brit pop American pop is
that right to say yeah Ramen
[Music]
actually it's pronounced
in Korean but these are kind of special
noodle because it's super spicy I always
bring it with me when I'm traveling
you know like I cannot eat ramen people
the day before the shooting but I always
take kick right after the shooting so
that I can release the stress from the
shooting or like you know drops that I
had today
like when I'm having this Ramen I think
it makes me Steam
like because of the spiciness
and it feels like it must not good at
healthy Health but like it feels like
you know I'm getting healthier so that's
why I'm taking this like super spicy
Ramen after the shooting
today wasn't stressful that much so I
don't think I'm gonna happen
[Music]
almost uh all item that I choose is
related to traveling has good style
obviously but it I can put many things
in one bag and then you know like I like
to wear shoulder back because if I need
my two hands free I mean I used to hate
my mom when she uh
like put too much things in her back
because of I feel like why you need that
you know but I think I'm doing the same
things with my mom
that I put so many things inside
I'm not gonna show you though I'm
getting more like my mom which I hate
this one it's actually my uh friends my
friend doing this brand called comfort
it's a crayon brand and they have this
kind of cute curing
and then it's actually the next things
I'm gonna talk about it's my cat
s are my favorite
my favorite
uh creature on the earth it's cat
they're my kind of when I'm hoarding
them it's just like hold my thoughts are
doesn't really necessary it's just all
about cats one is happier and one is
Mora
[Music]
I shouldn't be do this but like
I'm only having just one cat's photo on
my two phones so
one is for Korean one is for us
and I mean who can live without their
phones right I don't know why I'm having
two phones but
I kind of want uh you know like even
just photos and contacts from us and
Korea can be separated
so that I can be more organized but I
think it actually makes my life more
complicated what is the app that you use
the most oh let's check it out Instagram
kakaoto which is like WhatsApp in Korean
hello which is like you know you're
checking your period time and YouTube
Safari Gmail
that's it
[Music]
genifique
Essence serum you know in the airplane I
always like put layers because of it so
dry I always use it day in night in the
airplane everywhere
this is massage roller that I always
bring with me when I'm traveling you can
massage like neck and even like back and
also like legs with this just small
massage roller
it's very compact to take yeah it's just
like I need to do massage after you know
big long day of shooting or like
interview meetings
to relax
[Music]
thank you guys watching this video with
my horrible English
and see you next time hopefully bye